so I wanted to take us and put us inside
something very practical like a hospital
or health center and I'm a physician and
I have been given the new title I am
chief medical officer I haven't had a
lot of leadership or management training
I've been in relationships my whole life
and I got the book that they said you're
sort of in charge now how does what
you've just told me that this is a role
and it has something to do with
relationships how does that help me what
what do i do first what's the advice for
somebody in this situation well so the
first thing one thinks of is and it
takes some practice to realize this when
you've been given a title in a role is
the first thing I would say is you start
thinking I don't do this by myself now
that may seem like an easy and easy
sentence to say to somebody and yet most
of the rhetoric about leadership as we
talked about earlier is about it it's
you it's in you you do it it's part of
who you are it's your job so if the
first thing you stop and say to yourself
is I don't do this alone then the second
thing is who else do I do it with and
what do I need to do in order to make it
possible for those people to work with
me to support me too as as you know to
maybe even cover the places that I'm not
so good at and if somebody stepping into
a leadership role starts with I don't do
this alone
that's the essence of its leadership as
a relational concept and then starts to
ask the question who do I work with who
do I need who do I depend on and what do
I need to do to create those
relationships so that together we're as
effective as we can doing the tasks that
I've been given so I want to talk about
two kinds of relationships because it
seems as if as a clinician or a
physician I'm trained to really be sure
everything goes right and the idea that
I don't do this alone
a little terrifying because if something
goes wrong in the o.r and that is my
patient and I have not done it right
that is my fault
so now you're saying I don't when I take
that hat off and I go lead I don't do it
alone but what if these people who are
supposed to do it with me
just are not up to the task well that's
the terror right you go to the terror as
the limiting case I think most of the
time especially in situations where you
hire those people or you choose who
you're working with or you have the
capacity nobody's perfect every time to
help them develop and grow and become
better you're not really at the limiting
case most of the time where the people
you're working with are incompetent not
up to the task
usually the fear that the people we're
working with are incompetent or not up
to the task is fear of the
responsibility that comes with most
leadership roles my experiences the
reality is that nobody does it alone
we're just not put together that way
nobody is perfect that's a good thing
and so this deport or nobody in a
leadership role has the time energy
expertise to know all the different
facets of what he or she is responsible
for so this dependency this reliance on
others is critical and in fact in
critical situations like airline
cockpits up military theaters the actual
dependency on the other is is is more
important and the attention to
collecting the information and
compensating for what certain people
know and in that situation is extremely
important so even though more crucial to
tasks the more crucial this this
interdependence or this complementarity
is you're right that most organizations
and most of us carry on in our head that
it's just one person's responsibility
and that actually can make it harder for
us to to look to the places we need for
that complementarity or support yeah I
want to get back to complementarity in a
minute but I wanted to ask you first
whether you said there are a couple
things you would advise this new
physician who's been given the role and
one was to know don't do it alone you're
not doing it alone is there anything
else yeah so the second thing I would
probably say to somebody just taking the
the role is take a very hard look at
your own limitations and weaknesses
that's much easier said than done
first of all because most of us don't
like to look at those parts and second
of all as you suggested most of the
organizational settings in which these
appointments are made don't talk about
weaknesses or limitations in the people
who have leadership roles in fact they
would prefer if you didn't have any now
as I said before this of course is
insane since everyone in these roles has
them but the talk or the expectation
that one is going to be perfect or that
one is going to have no significant
limitations paired with our own lack of
willingness to look at those things
makes the simple statement take a look
at your limitations and weaknesses hard
look a difficult thing to do but I think
it's crucially important because there's
no way to make relationships with
subordinates or even peers to compliment
one's own limitations and weaknesses if
one doesn't have both an understanding
and some acceptance of the fact that
none of us is perfect so none of us is
perfect but some people are pretty
amazing and why do you think about the
people say we just need to get the right
person who is a good leader and we just
need to put them in the place they will
develop these relationships you're
talking about they'll understand the
role as long as we get the right person
we've got it I'm sensing from what you
said earlier this isn't quite right but
I think we hear it all the time I do
think we hear it all the time but I
think in a quiet moment you probably
wouldn't hear it from a person in a
leadership role that is what you hear
from the person a leadership role is all
the other people who were crucial to the
person's success and that's what you're
supposed to say publicly anyway that's
why I met if we could get inside the
brain
and if we could actually get
quote-unquote the truth I think most
people in leadership roles no they don't
do it on their own and they know that
various people who they work with were
absolutely crucial to their success not
just because they more people gives you
more time but because each of those
people contributed something that the
person in the role could not have done
they were trained that way they it's not
their normal so there's so much
diversity of people in leadership roles
in terms of what they're good at you
said well if we just got the right
person if it were that simple then
everybody in the leadership role would
look the same or everybody in a category
like private sector CEOs or Hospital and
yet when we look at successful people at
the head of hospitals they're not all
the same and that suggests to me that
that crucial skill is not what your
profile looks like but how you can
connect with people who compensate
compliment for the parts of your profile
that need to be complimented for and I
believe that people in leadership roles
to do that successfully are successful
at making relationships with people who
complement them and creating a
relational environment in which those
people can contribute what they think
what they see what their expertise is
okay so you've said complementarity now
a lot of different ways and it makes
sense that there's something when you're
in the leadership role you don't have
and you need to make a relationship with
somebody who does have that why don't we
do this this is this difficult yeah this
is very difficult as I'm sure you're
aware the the evidence on hiring
managerial hiring is that people hire
people who are like themselves if you
give these same people a questionnaire
and say do you think it's a good idea to
hire somebody like yourself they say no
most people are aware that having just a
lot of people who are the same working
in a in a in a CEO office or vice
president's and presence or managers and
sports is not a good idea
and most people hire people who are like
themselves and when you ask why
they say it's more comfortable and if
you pushed a little further I'm guessing
you might find that they say well I like
myself so I tend to like people like me
the problem is that that creates
oftentimes a one legged stool but it's
difficult in part because we like to be
comfortable and in part if you follow
this if I hire you and you're good at
something and I'm not good at and by
this I don't mean something trivial like
folding letters or stuffing envelopes
but something like you're much more
politically astute than I am
well then every day that we work
together and I see you being really good
at being political astute it reminds me
that I'm not so good at that and I have
to be pretty comfortable with what I'm
not terribly good at otherwise I'm not
gonna want to have you present to remind
me of this limitation or weakness that
I'm not comfortable with so I think
psychologically it's a very hard thing
to do and this is why you say step one
you've just gotten the job sit down and
really look yourself in the mirror and
figure out yep it is it I don't have and
usually that figuring it out requires
getting information from other people
it's hard to sit down and omit our eyes
distorts when we look at our own image
you know I don't look great myself but
of course I am so I think part of the
part of the work of getting that hard
look probably often involves getting
information from people that one trusts
about that who are able to say like my
children dad you look so white yeah
which then that convinces me that
actually I don't look okay so we have
two things one you said be sure you
recognize you don't do this alone and to
take a look at and maybe from your peers
and other people really get some real
information about what you're good at
what you're not good at is there
anything else so the last thing I would
say takes the part about one's own
limitations and weakness and goes to the
level of
groups and what I mean by that is
sometimes our capacity to think about
who and what might complement us is
constrained by the perceptions we have
of other groups so for example
oftentimes in in private sector
organizations and a senior executive
team somebody will say let's not bring a
lawyer in until later in the process
because you know how they what they'll
do and as a result they cut themselves
off from an area of information that
they're lacking right because of their
perception of we know what lawyers are
like this happens with all of us it's a
natural process and it can be a barrier
to making relationships with
complimentary others is our thoughts or
attitudes about the group's to which
they belong that those can be national
groups those can be functional groups
professional groups they can be identity
groups so the third thing I would say is
take a look at your quote-unquote
prejudices and buy prejudice I mean the
groups that we grow up having various
kinds of attitudes about like you were
using hospital examples like an MBA to
it to physicians to the chief medical
officer do I really have to talk to that
person or when that changes when I begin
to say to myself well just because I
don't have that expertise it's possible
that that body of knowledge may
contribute something then it makes it
easier for me to make a relationship
with people from those groups which then
makes it more likely that that
perspective on things that I don't have
because my training is as a physician
will be complemented by the training or
perspective of somebody from another
group I hear what you're saying but it
also is very uncomfortable you are a
let's not take a position you're an
executive of a pharmaceutical company
and you actually are thinking to
yourself I don't yeah I really don't
want the lawyers in here or I don't want
you know I don't want the women to be in
charge or I don't want people who are
young to be in charge it feels as if
being completely not politically correct
it feels as if you're stepping right
into what you shouldn't you're
stereotyping you're doing the worst of
the worst the things we try to hold our
back ourselves back from so how do you
really wrestle with that you're sort of
saying identify that person and
understand what group they are in and
how you feel about that group and yet
you're trying very hard not to
stigmatize people by whatever group
they're in so how do we possibly
reconcile this so I think it's the
difference between whether those
attitudes are in us and whether we
recognize them so as to be able to try
to manage them and I'm not in favor of
pretending we don't have them I don't
think it equips us to then adjust our
relationships try different things
expose ourselves to different people if
we're behind a veil that says I don't
have any attitudes towards other groups
this is an example since you brought up
gender a public record example in 1971
Richard Nixon was told by his political
people to appoint a woman to the Supreme
Court hmm never been a woman to the
Supreme Court in 1971 the United States
so he was open to this which is a shock
to me and and so he called in the head
of the American Bar Association a man
and he said my political people tell me
that that I should have pointed woman
the Supreme Court I'd like you to give
me two or three candidates and the head
of the American Bar Association in 1971
said there's not a single qualified
woman in the United States the coda to
that story which is patently ridiculous
but reveals I believe not not this the
head of the American Bar Association's
simply his his bigotry but rather his
belief about that group called women
lawyers and women judges that the coda
that is that of course Nixon appointed
two men thereafter who were both voted
down bipartisan Lee by the Senate on
competence growth I think it's a hard
thing to do but it's necessary and we do
it over time
so then you've told us to you know it's
a tough job you told us to first you get
this job you're not
really you haven't got that much
experience with that first thing no you
don't do it alone
second thing really take a deep look at
your own weaknesses strengths where you
might need shoring up and then third -
really if I'm getting you right to
really be honest with yourself about
your biases and your preconceptions I
think you call them previous prejudices
but your preconceptions about a group
that you might almost unconsciously
attach to the individual that you're
working with and thereby not make the
relationship very good those are very
tough times yes they are
I believe leadership is a tough role
yeah not to do well and and I don't
think it's it can be easily reduced to a
set of techniques so I think it is tough
work and as a psychologist I think it's
tough psychological work
you